- You're a fan favorite
on Real Housewives,
but your first season is almost done.
So would you come back?
Would you do it again?
- Well, we first have to
see if I'm invited back.
(audience laughs)
- Oh. I'm inviting you back to the show.
(both laugh)
I have no say, but I think you
should go back to the show.
- Well, this Friday we do the reunion,
so between that, and then meeting you,
I did not sleep last night.
- Oh!
- By the way, I love you so much.
I have Vaseline in my
mouth and on my teeth,
and my hands are freezing-
- I love you!
- And it's because of you and the reunion.
- Oh my gosh, that's so
awesome. That's so nice to know.
Wait, but the reunion
should be fun, right?
- Well, the reunion will be fun,
but what I'm trying to say is,
about two weeks after the reunion,
we find out if we're invited back.
- Man, they keep you going. Yeah, okay.
- I mean, I would love to.
- Yeah.
That's cool though, you loved it.
- I had really, a lot of fun.
- Yeah.